in an industry becoming more digital
every day nothing can replace the hands
that make our costumes stitch by stitch
every button and bead agonized over
until the gown flows the collar Peaks
the slipper fits and the past comes
alive tonight we honor the hands and the
talent of these incredible artists here
are the nominees for achievement and
costume design the grand budapest hotel
costume design by Melina cannon era
inherent vice costume design by mark
bridges into the woods costume design by
Colleen Atwood
Maleficent costume designed by Anna B
Shepard mr. Turner
costume design by Jacqueline DeRay and
the Oscar goes to
milena Kenan arrow the grand Budapest
thank you all of you thank you very much
bamboo they're caring and thank you yes
this is this is you
it's I should share with you you'll be
the greatest fear a show you are like a
conductor
you are like a composer you're like
you're our director and you inspire us
all of us that will be nominated here if
it wasn't for you this movie you know I
couldn't have done it this way and thank
you very much well thank you for life
aquatic thank you for the G Li limited
thank you for this and thank you all of
you